Gavin Nome did the best job I think
anyone possibly could and here's how you
want to roll back hard-earned National
rights on voting rights on civil rights
on lgbtq rights on women's rights not
just access to abortion but also access
to contraception you want to weaponize
grievance you are focusing on false
separateness you in particular Ron are
in a Banning binge a cultural Purge
intimidating and humiliating people you
disagree with you and and president
Trump are really trying to light
democracy on fire so Sean there are
profound differences tonight and I look
forward to engage him but there's one
thing in closing that we have in common
is neither of us will be the nominee for
our party in 20124 oh man that guy's
good if you're going to lose on the
facts of our society then you got to
reframe the debate away from the
realities of the present toward the
imagined horrors of the past